[Music]
so
this is a really really cool thing these
two gamers have formed an online
initiative called the watch what do you
think the watch does
stop child pedophiles
talking to kids now you're gonna make
the real thing look like it doesn't do
[ __ ] oh really oh sorry about that all
right it's a way better purpose
people that harass like streamers like
they go on
very close yeah yeah almost cyber
bullies yeah pretty much so they watch
the cyber bullying happen
why are you bullying him go on this is
good content
yeah commentating you ko him and all you
need is popcorn yeah
okay we got a on-site [ __ ]
cyberbullying happening right now let's
go let's go tune in let's go watch it
no they um so they have brought
something to the forefront which is
something that like if you play games
online you already know
playing call of duty with random people
you are going to hear the n-word the
f-word you can hear every kind of race
always done by some 12-year-old kid
and on top of all that there's never
anything you can do about it you can't
like report it because it already
happened like some guy isn't gonna go
all right go all right oh i hear him
okay cool we're gonna kill him like
nothing happens these kids get away with
all the time so these two gamers like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah we're tired of that
so what they're gonna do is they're
gonna um they're starting this
initiative which is gonna fight against
chat toxicity racism and sexism which is
also another big thing if they hear that
you're a girl
they dunk on you so hard dunk on you
like insanely so damn that's like a
super fun thing that will give you
somewhere to go if you notice somebody
said something or did something
you uh they're gonna come in and record
who's saying it
and what they're saying
and if activision or blizzard or all
these servers aren't going to do
anything about it they're going to
publicly put these things out well they
probably should man because it is
[ __ ] wild on this it's insane
it hasn't changed since i was like a kid
me too well that's why it doesn't really
like when you hear of things like oh my
god this celebrity said this it's like
bro you go on call of duty for one
minute you'll hear
times a million all these things and
it's always a pre-pubescent child oh
yeah that's like [ __ ] [ __ ] i
hate you yeah you [ __ ] kill your
whole family yeah yeah yeah yeah you
sound like a little girl they figured
out all the bad words that you're not
like like you know all the n words are
our words all those words you can't let
and they just go all at once
they throw it all at once like a word
they've never used that
to use it before they went in they got a
rush you're saying on their heads
they're just like i just said it
you know what i'm saying exactly get
away with it and all that [ __ ] it's like
it's wow it's like it's like you're uh
getting a rehearsal or like a test of
puffing up on people like for the first
time and it's oh that's more than fun
than the game itself yeah but then at
the same time it's like what you have
here is like a bunch of you know kind of
i'm gonna say mostly dumb kids just
because you know i was a dumb kid too
and you are just trying to do whatever
you can verbally to just hurt someone's
feelings yeah so you could win
yeah or because they did something to
you and then you guys start talking [ __ ]
it escalates to a point that there's
nothing capping it i'm sure it doesn't
create good social habits it's like i
don't think uh when like in elementary
school when you go to the bathroom and
you would just see like pee all against
the wall
and you're kind of just like
who did that yeah and why and you and
then and then you have a moment where
you're just like you know i was one of
those kids just
peed just because it was just like it's
just me and i can do it and when you do
it you're like
that felt amazing yeah i could just pee
all over the place it's just like when
you when you go back nobody knows what
happened it's like it's like egging a
house it's like
it's the vandalizing of it the thriller
is like but now you're doing it like
those type of things you know like
you're dealing with people's like
mentals you don't say
like let's say you do do that thing and
the teacher stops class and goes we need
to talk about who's been pissing on the
wall and it's you know it's you and
you're just like
yeah
that's [ __ ] up who does that it's not
cool man
peeing on the handlebar on the handle oh
man it's the word
it's literally the only is it's just to
troll yeah like it's the only thing
there's nothing else like i'm not mad at
nobody it's just one of those like
somebody's gonna be really pissed doing
things you're not supposed to as a kid i
mean even until now like i think boys
like we we get out of control like we do
it and it just escalates and escalates
and before you know it you're in tears
laughing but you're committed to crime
yeah that's both that's like boys
straight up straight up right yeah
straight up you're just like
throwing eggs turns into breaking
windows throw turns into like man i'm
burning this house down and you're
laughing with your friends and you're
like you should yeah well that escalated
quick
that really that starts quickly but
that's how it goes yeah that's i think
that's how it goes though and then
you're like oh because even with
bullying right like i remember
pranking was like we're pranking our
friends we're pulling tricks on them
like you know getting them like wet with
water but then
then um some kids don't fight back
so it's fun to [ __ ] prank them right
and they're bullying them and then it
turns into bullying because you're just
so addicted to [ __ ] with somebody
yeah and then like when you're what like
seven years old eight and then maybe up
until junior high you just don't know
how much it's [ __ ] with someone's
head yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the
thing is too though in this situation
like
in in the real world right there is a
some sort of sense of accountability
your parents will find out
yeah that's so true so it only takes the
most extreme of those to really get a
rise out of them but online just like on
facebook and all that other stuff like
twitter and stuff like that people are
trolling because there is no
accountability
that's the thing you want to hear like
like if you're on the other end and some
kid is trolling you're just saying all
these awful things to you but then you
hear like in the background you hear a
door open like what the [ __ ] are you
saying yeah and you hear an ass whooping
happen like on here while you're playing
again like that's something you want to
hear like you know the parents going in
there be like yo what the hell like
so another thing too is like when i i
still play call of duty with some
friends and then one of my friends i
play all the time with he's black and
every now and then like there'll be
another player in game you can create
your own uh i guess like flag for your
player so you can actually like draw
your own thing and sometimes people will
just draw straight up racist [ __ ] like a
swastika yeah like a straight up because
they're like they hear that he's he's
black well they just they'll they'll
just already be like that
so then like he already knows like oh
[ __ ] this guy and then he just
immediately starts going hey [ __ ] you
man
yeah and then it just like it just
starts from there back and forth but
even like that being allowed and not
being policed at all is like crazy when
you think about all the different
outlets that are trying at least like to
you know oh this comment got banned or
this account got deleted but call of
duty and online game servers have been
around for so long maybe they're like
this is our safe space where we can say
whatever the [ __ ] we want to each other
and we're keeping that safe here yeah
which always liked trolling but i never
liked bullying so i think my version of
that was on aol you you go in the chat
rooms i always pretended to be like a 15
year old girl and i was trying to try to
seduce dudes yeah oh wow that's actually
better for society
yeah it is like
hot barbie 69 yeah i'm like talking oh
my bra strap just fell down let me let
me put my bra strap back up and i'm like
trying to like talk like as if i was
your bra
because girls always talking about their
bra so what would be one of your go-to
lines what's it what was the go-to line
you would like
like because i have a dude's mind so i'm
like i'm probably doing it all wrong but
i'm like oh i got like a carrot in my
[ __ ] right now
like if it was an actual girl on the
other side
a girl on the other side would be like
this is not a [ __ ] chick but the guys
are so dumb they're like holy [ __ ] i hit
that jackpot she is not like any other
girl
i'm in love with this woman
i got a carrot in every hole
guys are so [ __ ] dumb should write
all the [ __ ] seductive sexual [ __ ] to
get the guys off though yeah you
probably all the guys that were chatting
with you were like you probably busted a
hell of a nuts yeah i got a guy a guy
needs to be on the hotline i really know
like what you need to hear you know it's
basically straight eye for the straight
guy
like it doesn't really
that's it for the straight guy
dick like right on the dick it's like
really like plain stuff
because women are like oh i just can't
get men you know like this is so
complicated and mark's like no worry i
got you move over yeah give me your
computer all this [ __ ] doing your nails
getting ready don't even worry about it
just put a carrot in your [ __ ] you
really have a carrot you need to talk
about it
i am wearing a baggy white t-shirt
jumping on a trampoline and it's raining
outside my titties are just bouncing
yeah
[Laughter]
dude you should work for chris hanson
and just catch petals oh dude
can you imagine romance novels for men
by men
wait do we even read
we will after this guy right
that's basically hentai manga no like a
straight guy wrote that and you're just
like trying to be turned off like this
is tired
yeah you be like bro he [ __ ] gets me
bro
bar quad is sick dude
this guy's the
thing 24 karat magic you know they're
how do best
like
man guys straight guys really know how
to make me the horniest
you turn the book around you see his
photo he's like portrait of the author
oh this guy
this is the dude
[Music]